foreign
this is Roger Penrose certainly one of
the great scientists of our time winner
of the 2020 Nobel Prize in physics for
his work reconciling black holes with
Einstein's general theory of relativity
but back in the 1970s Roger Penrose made
a contribution to the world of
mathematics and that part of mathematics
known as tiling
you know tiling the process of putting
tiles together so that they form a
particular pattern
the thing that was remarkable about the
pattern that Roger Penrose developed is
that by using only two shapes he
constructed a pattern that could be
expanded infinitely in any direction
without ever repeating much like the
number Pi has a decimal that isn't
random but it will go on forever without
repeating
in mathematics this is a property known
as a periodicity and the notion of an
aperiodic tile set using only two tiles
was such a sensation it was given the
name Penrose tiling here's Roger Penrose
now sir Roger Penrose standing on a
field of Penrose tiles
then in 2007 this man Peter Liu who was
then a graduate student in physics at
Princeton while on vacation with his
cousin in Uzbekistan
discovered this pattern on a 14th
century madrasa and after some analysis
concluded that this was in fact Penrose
tiling 500 years before Penrose
that information took the scientific
World by storm and prompted headlines
everywhere including discover magazine
which proclaimed this the 59th most
important scientific discovery of the
year 2007.
so now we've heard about this amazing
pattern from the point of view of
mathematics and from physics and now art
and Archeology so that leads us to the
question what was there about this
pattern that this ancient culture found
so important that they put it on their
most important building
so for that we look to the world of
anthropology and ask the question what
was the world view of the culture that
made this and this is what we learned
this pattern is life
and as you can see
life's complicated
it's complicated but not only is life
complicated life is also aperiodic in
the sense that every event every
happening every decision will make the
future unfold differently often in ways
that are impossible to predict
yet in spite of the complexity and in
spite of a future that's impossible to
predict there remains an underlying
Unity that holds everything together and
gives rise to everything let's see how
that works in a design much like the one
Peter Liu found in Uzbekistan
this is that design now it turns out
this is actually based on this set of
Penrose tiles which are reducible to
these shapes
and in order to draw these shapes the
medieval Craftsman who did this would
have done them by using these
construction lines and I add here that
that the construction lines don't appear
in the final work
but if we add them back
we have this and now if we weave them
together we will have this and now if we
hide the tiles and just look at the
construction lines
we see this
clearly there's an underlying structure
and unity to things that seem to be
complex and aperiodic
this notion of a hidden underlying Unity
was common throughout the ancient world
and one sees it in Egypt
in Greece
in Australia
in mesoamerica
in North America
in Europe
and in the Middle East
now in the modern West we might call
this underlying Unity God but throughout
the ages other terms have been used to
describe the same thing this is what
Plato called first cause
in the medieval period philosopher
Spinoza called this the singular
substance
in the 20th century a number of terms
were coined to describe this one of my
favorites being from philosopher Alfred
North Whitehead who called this the
undifferentiated aesthetic continuum
that doesn't that have a 20th century
sound to it
uh but but for me a lover of science
that I am I will take the term coined by
the great 20th century physicist David
mom who called this the implicate order
so what's the takeaway here very simply
this when we see these wonderful designs
created by cultures that are separated
from our own by thousands of miles or
thousands of years we can know these
aren't decorations these are statements
about the fundamental values that
culture had what they found important
how they saw themselves the world and
themselves in the world
it has been said that architecture is a
book written in stone
so when we see these amazing designs we
can know they're not decorations they're
a statement they're a message look
listen
you can hear their voices
thank you
[Applause]